quatorze jours cela fait quatorze jours
et 14 nuits que les volets du pavillon
des bertrand sont clos ici à
pont-sainte-marie faubourgs de 3 à
l'intérieur la tante l'angoissent de
toute une famille à l'extérieur la
presse la presse utile quand on a besoin
de donner le maximum de publicité au
rapt mais une presse que l'on accuse
aussi de tous les maux à la moindre
bavure
la dernière en date la rançon n'a pas
été récupéré par les ravisseurs
et l'enfant n'a pas été libéré par ce
que dit la famille la presse en a parlé
trop tôt or ni la police ni la justice
n'ont sur ce point demandé à la presse
d'être discrète bien au contraire
sur place des allées et venues du père
et du grand-père de philippe continue
pour eux depuis deux semaines leur
univers c'est la villa de la rue du
docteur roux le palais de justice
l'hôtel de police l'hôtel de police où
depuis 24 heures un homme est gardé à
vue un homme jeunes appréhendés au
volant d'une simca 11/100 rouge sur le
parking d'un supermarché de 3 on vérifie
son emploi du temps nous a dit le juge
d'instruction